we got a lot of catching up to do hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be revisiting the
revised season two of olivia dondrea's
globe diaries following up from my
previous review which you can watch
right here but first let me tell you
about my sponsor wild now when i was
pregnant with e i started using natural
deodorant but i honestly found that most
of them i tried actually made me smell
worse so i was really excited to try out
wild's natural deodorant especially
because of its unique sustainability
efforts so first of all wild is aluminum
and paraben free and because it's not an
antiperspirant it doesn't clog pores
most importantly though it actually
works like it is freezing outside in
canada and it doesn't actually matter
because i still sweat so much and no one
has complained about me smelling so
that's a win to me now the way it works
is that you pick your favorite reusable
customizable case choose your plan pick
your sense add on any soap or a mini
deodorant for travel and then you can
use my promo code abby20 to get 20 off
of your order for the holiday season
they actually have just launched their
limited edition gold case and their
festive scent trio pack including my
favorite the cinnamon and nutmeg which
literally smells like a sugar cookie
it's so good but most of all i love that
this is a uniquely sustainable choice
even the refill packaging is made out of
bamboo and it's 100 biodegradable so you
can just chuck it into the compost when
you're done and the best news is that
they ship worldwide and you can choose a
one-off purchase or a subscription so if
you want to give wild a try check out
the link in my description and use my
promo code abby20 to get 20 off of your
order before we get into it you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always you can
feel free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and of course
if you're new here do not forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
and don't forget to follow me over on
instagram and on tick tock at abby's
kitchen to quickly recap the series thus
far olivia embarked on her glow-up
journey when she was 18 years old in an
effort to lose weight before university
boost her confidence and become her best
self now in season one she documented
her tumultuous relationship with food
along with her intense struggles with
restriction binge eating and over
exercising but after three years on this
journey at the age of 21 years old she
finally claims to have glowed up in her
relationship with food now i want to
note that at the time of filming this
review olivia has only released three
episodes of season two so unfortunately
we won't be able to capture the full
breadth of her glow up journey but of
course if you want me to revisit the
series as more videos become available
definitely leave me a comment below but
for now we're going to be chatting about
some of my main concerns and takeaways
from olivia's glow-up journey so far my
first big flag here is that i feel her
support system isn't really supportive
at all
in a video that was initially included
as part of season two olivia consulted
with the liberty fitness trainer steve
zim who she credits for helping her lose
32 pounds and
quote succeed now in the video steve
shares his weight loss guide which i
discussed in detail in my previous globe
diaries review but to briefly recap
steve is among the fitness trainers out
there who i would say predominantly
focuses on aesthetic goals like weight
loss by implementing a militant kind of
no pain no gain mentality
and we often hear olivia herself align
with that in a lot of her videos now the
issue with believing that you have to
suffer a lot in order to lose weight is
that it can make disorderly behaviors
like under eating and severely over
exercising feel
justified normal and necessary even when
they feel very wrong to the body and if
you already struggle with disordered
eating as olivia herself suggests that
she does this mentality can do even more
harm what is even more concerning here
is that steve clearly had no
understanding or insight towards
olivia's extreme binge restrict
tendencies which makes his advice to
under eat and get fit at any cost even
more dangerous this is a trainer not a
therapist dietitian or doctor who is
very much ill-equipped to deal with the
complexities of a very real mental
health issue and i don't fault olivia
for taking his advice i mean when you're
in a desperate and vulnerable place
you're really at the mercy of anyone who
walks and talks like a trusted source
but this type of advice will only
further complicate olivia's relationship
with food and entrench her deeper in
disordered diet mentality now when it
doesn't work out with steve she reaches
out to what she calls a nutritionist
food therapist let's take a quick look i
am
at a really low point with my eating now
which is why i'm going to reach out for
help so i reached out to this woman who
was a food therapist slash nutritionist
and it didn't work for me the only
person that can truly save you at the
end of the day is yourself like there's
this perception of therapy that if i
just go to a therapist all my problems
are gonna be solved first and foremost i
just want to applaud olivia for having
the courage to reach out for help i mean
this is really just not a fight that she
needs to fight alone and the support of
a trained mental health professional may
be essential for helping her just to
rebuild healthier coping strategies and
to get to the emotional route of some of
her binge eating but despite being open
to receiving some support it sounds like
it just wasn't a good fit and that does
happen now i don't have a whole lot more
information on this experience but i do
have a few thoughts one a nutritionist
food therapist isn't a regulated title
so i'm really not sure if this was like
an actual therapist or a psychologist or
maybe it was a dietitian but i
definitely do suggest finding a trusted
evidence-based therapist and dietitian
team and these are usually two different
people to help tackle the emotions
behind the eating and also help with the
nutrition piece on the other side you
know it's possible that this was a
legitimate eating disorder therapist and
or dietitian and olivia just like didn't
click with their advice possibly because
they were advising her to put weight
loss on the back burner and as i
discussed with my colleague in my video
on amberlynn read right here when
there's an active eating disorder at
play weight loss needs to be taken off
the table for the most part we really
cannot stop the binging if we're stuck
in scarcity mentality and constantly
attempting to restrict and that brings
me to point number two that her glow up
is still strongly dependent on weight
loss even though olivia cut out the
controversial weight loss focused
episodes the dominant flavor of this
glow up journey still remains the same
now on the one hand we often hear a
script that references her glow up in
like a classic empowering and
inspirational tone makes life wonderful
isn't what you're given it's what you
create with your hands and your mind
making beautiful things out of ugly
situations you go through growing up is
a beautiful state of mind where you
become disciplined in your actions being
there for yourself when nobody else is
pushing yourself beyond what you thought
you were capable of developing gratitude
being unapologetically your authentic
self but in more scripted moments we see
the narrative come back to weight loss
there's just no excuses but i'll just
explain why i gained weight it had been
almost a year and a half since i started
this glow-up journey and i was heavier
than ever i couldn't figure it out why
couldn't i be consistent with weight
loss why did i always binge why did it
seem like i had no self-control with
food i just don't get it and at that
point
all i thought i wanted was to be skinny
i didn't understand anything about
fitness or the food choices i was making
i just kind of thought it was purely
calories in and calories out if glowing
up was about a beautiful state of mind
would we have i don't know like glowed
down for gaining 10 pounds and would we
be insinuating that the glow up failed
because we haven't maybe met our goal
weight i mean if you watch the series
very carefully there's also a lot of
implicit suggestions of what glow up
actually means despite the self-care in
spo verbiage most of her references to
her glowed-up self are footage of her in
a noticeably smaller frame and a happier
disposition just to pose against her
larger free glow-up body now i don't
want to invalidate olivia's experience
and the role that weight loss may have
played in boosting her confidence and
happiness i mean if being in a smaller
body made her truly happier and
healthier then amazing like that's the
goal but when confidence happiness
self-worth and sense of self are
contingent on the number on the scale we
risk falling apart when that number goes
up and olivia is so young i mean there
are going to be so many seasons of life
where that number is going to go up as a
viewer completely uninvested in her
weight i can see so many other ways
olivia has glowed up in her journey that
are just not getting the screen time
that her weight struggles do i would
love to see her focus the rest of the
season on some of the more nuanced
successes now finally my third
observation is that her tough mindset
may be sabotaging her relationship with
food so throughout the series and also
in some of her supplementary videos we
hear olivia share a few mindset rules
that she implements as a way to hold
herself accountable and keep her
disciplined in her goals so things like
practicing mental toughness even when
she wants to give up or
doing uncomfortable things so she can
grow and while there may be some merit
to this approach in some contexts or
situations as a professional i am
solidly against them when it comes to
food especially for a young woman who
already struggles in her relationship
with food in one of her videos from
february which was filmed after episode
1 but was not officially made part of
the series possibly because of the
initial backlash but anyways she
discusses practicing delayed
gratification with food and avoiding
food cravings by telling herself that
they are just thoughts
my family made three pizzas i purposely
waited to eat the third pizza because i
wanted to practice delaying
gratification it starts in the little
things so i had one slice after that i
felt an urge to eat more but i reminded
myself those are just thoughts and went
to get a healthy replacement a salad
this is balance i replace the second
slice of pizza with a salad so
lots to unpack first of all it's
important to point out that on this
particular day olivia also engaged in
excessive amounts of exercise so these
are more than just thoughts it makes
total sense that her body would be
physically craving more calories from
the excessive activity and it would also
make sense that it would be mentally
begging for more of her kind of
forbidden or bad foods since she is
living in a perpetual state of
deprivation and discomfort that is
begging to be rewarded
award
you never mentioned
an award so this is more than just
thoughts it's primal survival mode and
while trying to implement mental
toughness to outsmart hunger may
work temporarily the body will
eventually overpower the mind it's
designed to do that in order to survive
it's like trying to deny yourself sleep
or going to the bathroom you can only
prolong it so long before you just crash
or you yourself or in olivia's case you
binge and in this case trying to crowd
these cravings out or cover them up with
a healthy replacement like salad just
resulted in olivia secretly binching on
cake so i would strongly encourage
olivia to implement the mindset of
self-care over self-control and to do so
with the support of a trained eating
disorder professional who's able to help
her identify some of these patterns and
help her find some more supportive
gentle solutions now because a lot of
her videos aren't filmed chronologically
it is hard to see like a straight line
progress and even if they were we would
expect this journey to be up and down
but i do want to highlight some moments
where i do see some improvements and
growth from this place so first of all
in episode one we saw olivia
characterize exercise as punishment used
to chastise herself for cheating on her
diet uh i'm riding the bike
to go to the club after i literally just
got ready i mean at least i'm staying
fit i did have
one too many cookies today now by
episode three we start to see a more
gentle kind approach to movement at
times going to work out to um like burn
calories or anything because i don't
believe in burning off food you just ate
like just to burn off one small cookie
you have to run a mile
i just feel like going to work out
because
i feel really like sad right now like i
just want to let it out
[Music]
so by connecting movement with the
experience of feeling energized strong
and alive we're actually less likely to
see it as something to loathe seven
o'clock wrestle with myself loathing
i'm booked or that requires mental
toughness to maintain it becomes an act
of body celebration self-care and a
healthy outlet for emotion management
it's there when it feels good and it
serves you but it isn't something that
you need to drag yourself through when
it does not i was also encouraged that
as the season progresses we start to see
some introspection on the root cause of
her binging episodes why couldn't i be
consistent with weight loss why did i
always binge why did it seem like i had
no self-control with food food choices i
was making i just kind of thought it was
purely calories in and calories out but
including myself is that starving
yourself doesn't lead to happiness or
even getting thin for that matter i
ended up gaining weight through that
experience because i had so many binge
days and i ended up more unhappy than
before i started so i think olivia
perfectly articulates the problematic
diet culture messaging that we're
socialized to believe you know the whole
nothing tastes as good as skinny feels
trope or whatever distorted bull kate
moss said
folks restriction causes binge eating
binge eating triggers guilt and shame
guilt feeds into further restriction
rinse and repeat textbook binge restrict
cycling here now the first step is to
acknowledge the cycle and it's really
encouraging to me that she seems to be
getting to that place now while i
imagine the details of how she's got
here will unfold in upcoming episodes in
her july video she does admit to finally
gaining more clarity around her binge
eating disorder and kind of some of the
psychological triggers that have played
into her symptoms like shame and
negative self-talk she also shares that
she's proud of herself for being in the
healthiest relationship with food that
she's ever been in and is no longer
assigning moral value to food she says
she's learned to see a cookie as just a
cookie you gave me cookie i got you
cookie man not something that's good or
bad which ultimately gave her the
freedom to tune into how food is making
her feel both physically and emotionally
better yet she also claims to have let
go of her reliance on mental toughness
to achieve her goals because it closes
her off from true happiness according to
olivia she's gone to a place where she
just accepts herself for who she is
which in her words is a messy
adventurous courageous girl in progress
well like i said recovery is not going
to be a straight forward line and this
is evidenced by a statement she makes to
kick off her november video on healthy
homey meals the food you eat can either
be the safest and most powerful form of
medicine or the slowest form of poison
if we want to stop moralizing food and
moralizing ourselves for our food
choices we need to stop referring to any
food as poison
[Music]
or medicine we cannot give it that power
and while i am seeing more balance in
olivia's meal so quinoa chicken veggies
and avocado on monday we got rice beyond
meat and some veggies on wednesday an
acai bowl with lots of toppings on
friday lots of good stuff here but
almost all of the carbs shown in the
recipes are things that she says she
personally doesn't eat she says she
doesn't eat rice so she serves it with
cauliflower rice and she doesn't eat
noodles in the soup so she leaves them
out of hers she even goes off about the
sugar content of sriracha as if one
teaspoon of sugar and six calories per
teaspoon of sauce is going to completely
ruin her diet so like i said recovery is
going to be a marathon not a sprint
acknowledging which thought patterns are
not serving you is step one and i am so
happy to see that being articulated but
actually modifying the behaviors is
going to be a whole other more
challenging step of the journey
especially if she's still holding on to
hope of changing her body
but if i had any advice for olivia it
would be to get the right team on board
and even if you don't like to hear it if
their recommendation is to put weight
loss on the back burner we've got to put
that aside because any weight loss
incurred through a punishing regimen is
never going to be maintained or done in
the name of health so on that note folks
that is all that i have for you guys
today if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
if you'd like to hear more about this
series if you want more videos to come
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and i'll see you next time
bye